could the weather be any better for the
last plenary session in Strasburg before
the holidays but before we leave for the
recess here's a look at some of the big
topics for autumn welcome to the agenda
it's been the biggest story could grease
make a deal with creditors and stay in
the eurozone here in Strasburg at the
last plenary session of the summer MVP's
invited Greek Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras 'nope tempers flared as them
criticised the Prime Minister while
others offered their advice at the final
hour a deal was struck in Brussels and
later passed by the Greek parliament but
not without a bitter struggle tough
months lie ahead MVP's will continue to
monitor the situation and some are even
calling for a rethink of a eurozone
blueprint the transatlantic trade deal
has avoided a hangman's noose more times
than you can count but is it worth a
fight by doing away with regulatory
barriers across a wide range of areas
like manufacturing food or transport
figure suggests that tea tip would boost
ease economy by 120 billion euros
four-point-five percent of GDP and
create millions of jobs the critics
argue that changes to the labour market
could actually create unemployment walk
two down EU standards and need to
increase privatisation as US companies
move in on public services but the
biggest snag is isds the private
arbitration mechanism where you
governments could be sued both private
investors the original isds method has
been shot down by an EPS the what form
it now takes is still unclear but choppy
waters to navigate in the coming months
will Parliament give teens a good seal
of approval or banish it for good is
Europe's obsession with security deadly
that's what protesters had to say when
they staged a protest and the waters
outside the Court of Human Rights in
Strasbourg to show their solidarity with
a thousands of migrants who have died
trying to cross the waters of the
Mediterranean into Europe a tragedy that
saw hundreds drown of the Mediterranean
coast in April was the catalyst that
finally galvanized European leaders to
come up with a solution to the migrant
crisis but getting the action plan up
and running
has been no easy task the sticking
points were relocation in all EU members
days of forty thousand migrants already
arrived in Italy in Greece and the
resettlement of 20,000 refugees coming
from third countries your midst oh you
day the finer details how to go about
doing this I'll still to be decided with
some around the corner MVP's gave
consent to provide an extra 60 9.6
million euros of funding to Frontex to
help manage the situation better and in
december the civil liberties committee
will present their own initiative report
to the plenary and now for some stories
expected to hit the headlines in the
autumn it's become trendy to go organic
the industry is expanded so rapidly in
the last five years that better quality
controls are needed labeling neither
quality ensuring measures are on the way
it's a law that could redefine the food
we eat novel foods which could soon
include algae fungi and would you
believe it insects will be subject to
stricter safety measures with the
Parliament voting on proposed
legislation in October despite being
shelved by the Commission the air
quality package could be making a return
with a few tweaks could the air we
breathe get cleaner you'll have to find
out in October a morally corrupt but
legal tax system that allows member
states to give favorable tax breaks to
multinationals could be set to change in
November Parliament special committee on
tax set up in the wake of the Lexus
scandal will issue its recommendations
could europe give a helping hand to its
flagging economy one idea being proposed
is a capital markets union by 2018 we'll
find out more on the project gains
momentum in october the civil liberties
committee approved a draft passenger
name record text that includes strong
data protection safeguards negotiations
with other institutions will begin
shortly the last step is sometimes hard
to make so too for the final pillar of
the railway package reforms affecting
domestic travel technical issues have
now been resolved to expect movement on
the right track next term with co2
levels rising dramatically the
environmental impact the next 30 years
could be devastating the need for a
global climate change agreement is now
more than ever can it be reached in
Paris the big polluters like China and
the US are finally on board so it's
looking positive that a global agreement
can be reached to lower emissions will
this be the last tango in paris or will
world leaders default and saving the
environment wait and see in december and
as all we have this agenda take care and
enjoy the holidays
you